KELLY SANTIAGO: Thanks so
much for joining us today
to talk about
Tango and what it's
like to work on the
platform and why
our developers find it important
to build on the platform.
So just as a little background--
so I'm Kelley Santiago.
I co-founded an independent game
development studio years ago
called That Game Company.
Then I worked at the Android--
thank you-- Android-based
console Ouya.
Little woo?
Mini woo?
Working with developers.
And now I'm super
excited to be working
with even more pioneering
developers on our new projects
under the Google VR banner.
So Project Tango is a
platform that gives developers
the abilities to build apps that
understand space and motions.
Over the past 2 and
1/2 years, we've
had over 6,000 developers
building applications ranging
from interactive games that
you may have checked out
in the Sandbox-- and
if you haven't, you
should totally check them out--
to tools to help architects.
We are really fortunate
to have with us
today a group of
Project Tango developers
building very different apps.
So with that, I'm actually going
to let them-- because it is I/O
and I feel like you're here to
hear from developers and people
working on the platform.
So I'm going to let the
panelists introduce themselves
and talk a little bit about
what brought them to Tango
and what they're working on.
JOEL PENNINGTON:
I'm Joel Pennington,
and I work at Autodesk.
And my job is to take
technology from the film, game,
and TV industry and bring
it to the hands of folks
in the other industries that
Autodesk creates software for.
And that manifests itself
in visualization tools today
for architects, engineers,
construction professionals--
folks that build anything.
It's part of our future
of making things movement.
And what we're doing today
with the Tango tablet
is we're giving the amazing
film production tools that you
get if you're creating Avatar
in the form factor of a tablet
that everyone gets
and understands
and deliver it to an architect
to let him or her explain
their design to their clients
in a way that was never
possible before.
ROBIN HUNICKE: All
right, I'm Robin Hunicke
I am the co-founder of
Funomena here in San Francisco.
I actually worked
at That Game Company
with Kelly on a
game called Journey,
and then afterwards, I came
back up to the Bay Area
because I love it here
and founded this company.
And my background is in
artificial intelligence
and robotics.
I worked on the Sims and some
other simulation-based games
before moving into
what we call deep games
or emotionally-based games, of
which Journey is an example.
And I'm really interested
in the intersection
between new technologies
and game development.
And so Tango is one
of the many projects
that we work on at Funomena that
push our boundaries in terms
of understanding leading
edge technologies, things
that are new, new ways of
approaching the space of play.
And specifically what I liked
about Tango is the ability
to build a world-- the thing
that we work on is called
woorld, w-o-o-r-l-d and it
is in the Sandbox area--
with other people by passing
this view port around
and seeing the world from
a different perspective.
And so the best
thing about it is
that it lets me work with
my designer Keita Takahashi.
He's most famous for
developing Katamari Damacy
and letting his irreverent
understanding of the world
become real through this lens.
So it's been a really
fantastic experience.
KYLE NEL: Cool.
I'm Kyle and I don't
have a cool intro song,
but I'll work on that.
I'm Kyle Nel, and I'm
the executive director
of the Lowe's Innovation Labs.
And Lowe's Home Improvement--
it's a big Fortune 50 North
American home
improvement company.
So our group, we build
stuff you wouldn't
expect a Lowe's to build with
people you wouldn't expect
us to build it with,
and I think this
is a great example of that.
We've done a lot of
other things too,
but this one, in particular,
is a persistent problem--
a customer problem.
Has anyone done a home remodel?
A lot of sad nods.
It's really hard, and one
of the biggest problems
is not having the inability
to buy the thing you want.
It's really the
visualization and trying
to understand how a
lot of different things
could happen in your
space and then communicate
that with the
other person that's
making that decision with
you-- your significant other
or whoever.
And that inability to
get that out of your head
or to understand what it will
look like just stops people
from doing projects,
and that really, really
hampers what we're
trying to help people
do, which is improve their
homes and help people
wherever they live.
So Tango is uniquely
situated and suited
to be able to meet that need,
and we're really, really
excited to be part
of this group.
JESSE SHELL: Hi,
I'm Jesse Shell.
Formally, I was the creative
director of the Disney Virtual
Reality Studio back in the 90s.
For the past dozen
years or so, I've
been teaching at Carnegie Mellon
and running a place called
Shell Games out of
Pittsburgh, which
is a team of about 100
game developers doing
all kinds of things.
We were first drawn to Tango
because part of what we do
are interactive theme
park installations,
interactive museum exhibits.
We love this idea of being
able to mix digital with space.
And while that was initially
what we were completely focused
on, we quickly found
that, wow, there
are a lot of just super fun
game things you can do with it.
Because we're always on
the lookout for things
that are magical, and we were
really pleased at how magical
the Tango technology can be.
KELLY SANTIAGO: Cool.
So Robin, I was hoping
you could kick it off
with talking about what's been
a surprising challenge for you?
And then maybe that will inspire
some of the other panelists
to weigh in as well.
ROBIN HUNICKE: Sure.
So the thing that I'm really
interested in right now
is that VR and AR technologies
really involve two things.
They involve the body and
our perception of reality.
And you can think of those
things as the same thing,
but there's the
physical embodiment
of motion and the
activity that you do when
you're in a VR or an AR space.
And then there's also
the way that your body
interprets signals that are
coming into it to turn it
into reality.
And so one of the
biggest challenges for me
personally with
augmented reality
is that unlike an experience
where you're cutting out
all of the world, you
have to really work
alongside the world.
And if you're a designer
type of person like me,
you are particular about
how things look and feel.
And so building
something that has
a real aesthetic,
like a feeling,
but also having it be able to
work in any kind of environment
with any number of ugly
pieces of furniture
or random detritus
on the table--
that sort of stuff--
for me, it just
gnaws at my designer
sensibilities.
And so one of the
things that we found
challenging when we first
started working with Tango was
how do we build a consistent
aesthetic experience that
looks cool and feels like it
came from Keita's imagination,
for example?
Because he has a very classic
and interesting style.
His work is in the Museum of
Modern Art in New York City.
He's a well-known designer.
How do we take that
design aesthetic
and put it out into spaces
that could maybe be completely
cluttered or totally empty?
And what was really
interesting was that getting
past that challenge, we were
able to think about the fact
that we don't need
to design everything.
What we really need to
do is design the space
just in front of you--
the attentional activity
that you're interested in.
Give you a sound cue, draw
your attention somewhere else.
And so it started to give us a
different surface to design on.
We started thinking a
lot more about the body
and the attention of the body
as we interacted with the space.
So it was a challenge, but
it was also eye opening.
And I think, honestly,
it has made us all better
developers at Funomena.
KELLY SANTIAGO: How about Joel?
JOEL PENNINGTON: Well, when
we take a look at the way
that directors today create
films in the virtual production
world, we've solved
many of the problems
around interacting with a world
that doesn't physically exist.
And the challenge
for us was taking
that, which is million dollar
equipment, hundreds of people
working in the background, and
putting that onto the Tango
tablet and making it work for an
architect who doesn't know how
to make a film, doesn't
know about film production
technologies, but is able to
communicate the design idea.
And when we worked with
the folks at Tango,
we were able to enlist a
number of charter architects
that let us develop
this in concert
and create a research platform
at Autodesk that allows us
to fully visualize
and experiment
with this new way of
interacting with your designs.
KELLY SANTIAGO: So what I think
would be really interesting
is to talk about-- you've
all been working with this
in the field now for
a bit and probably
have some learnings from
focus testing and user
testing that you've been doing.
What are some surprising things?
Maybe Kyle, you
can start us off?
KYLE NEL: My background is
in applied neuroscience.
So there's two sides
of neuroscience.
There's the physician
side, and then there's
the hardware / software nerds.
You probably can fit
which one I was in.
So anyway, one of the
things we built early on
at Lowe's surprisingly was an
applied neuroscience company.
So we actually put
high rez EEG headsets
on people and eye-tracking
goggles and we tested.
And Tango-- our
application of Tango--
is not our first venture into
virtual and augmented reality.
We've done a number of things.
Net platform we call
the hollow room.
So we've been testing different
iterations, including Cardboard
and others, using applied
neuroscience, which
is far better-- as
a social scientist,
a far better thing
than asking somebody
what they thought of it only.
Or did you see the
button on the left?
Because then you're
biasing the response.
And so we could see
very quickly what
was working and not working.
But most interestingly,
the biggest measure-- one
of the big measures we
test for is this thing
called cognitive load, which
is how much your brain is
having to work.
Now, there's a sweet spot.
You don't want it
to be underwhelming
where you're not engaged.
Have you ever drove to work
and you get out of your car
and you're like, I don't
even remember driving.
That's really low cognitive
load and it concerns me.
But we've all done it, right?
And then there's too
much, and that is bad too.
You want to hit that sweet
spot, which is very, very hard.
And as we did all
this testing, we
saw that Tango more
intuitively hit that sweet spot
on a number of measures.
Back to what she
was saying, too,
about how you have to have
this intuitive form factor.
And this is a far more intuitive
form factor for right now.
So we're really
excited about that.
But there's still so many
different ways to iterate
and serve up content
and the experience
with the functionality,
and that's
back to the question
about challenge.
It's been interesting for
us to take-- OK, well, we
think this is the answer based
on what we just saw and we
put that in and then it
creates a whole bunch
of other potential challenges.
But it's just been really great
to work with a Google team
and use the neuroscience
and then put it in the field
very quickly in front
of real, actual people
to see how they respond to it.
It's been great.
KELLY SANTIAGO: Jesse,
what about with your work?
You've done a
variety of projects.
So what have you been learning
through watching people play?
JESSE SHELL: I guess
what we're finding
is that the shift to
making Tango experiences
is almost as big a
shift as when we went
from mouse-based and
gamepad-based gameplay
to touch-based gameplay.
Because when we went to
touch, we had to reinvent UI.
We had to invent this whole
new language of the way you
interact with things.
And what was intuitive
was really different.
And what we're
finding, the same key
that we found back
with touch games
is the same key now, which
is watch what children do.
Because children are way
smarter than the rest of us
because we've all
been trained up
on all kinds of broken
nonsense in our brains.
When you give adults
Tango, what we
find is we'll be doing games and
trying to show them how to play
and adults sometimes are
like, well, how do I move?
I'm like, well, you move.
You just move.
Well, how do I zoom in?
Where's the zoom button?
I'm like, you zoom in.
It's right there
in front of you.
Get closer to it.
But you never have to
tell this to children.
And we have to use this
logic on ourselves.
We had a thing where we're
making this one game where
you can set up big rows of
dominoes all over the place
and then you can
knock them all down,
which is super fun because
you can do it very fast
and you don't have
to clean them up.
It's really nice.
You just hit a button
and they stand up again.
You can change it around.
And we wanted to be able to move
the whole set that we've made.
And I was like, yeah, let's
put in little buttons that
move it to the left and right.
And the developers
were like, no, stupid,
you just move them all
to the left and right.
Just pick them up.
Oh yeah, I can do that.
So it's learning these
new, more intuitive powers.
It's almost more like
un-learning is what you
have to do in order to use it.
KELLY SANTIAGO: Yeah,
that's really interesting.
Would you recommend a
certain breadth of audience
when you're conducting a
focus test or user test?
Oh
JESSE SHELL: Yeah.
KELLY SANTIAGO: Have all ages?
JESSE SHELL: If you want to
sell to a lot of people, sure.
KELLY SANTIAGO: But you find
kids give meaningful feedback?
JESSE SHELL: I find
they're best at showing you
intuition-- natural
human intuition, that is.
You still need the
test with adults
because you've got to learn
all of the unintuitive behavior
that they've learned
and figure out
how you're going to unravel
that and get them back
to something natural.
But it can be very helpful to
test with kids for that reason.
ROBIN HUNICKE: It's
also really great
to test with people
that are not necessarily
in the realm of
gamer or experienced
super user like myself.
Because we tend to develop
things for ourselves.
We make them tweakier so
that we can be very precise.
We want to add all this detail.
And if you just put someone
who has never even tried
a virtual reality or an
augmented reality technology
into the experience,
you almost always
get questions that reflect
back to your own ignorance,
your own written in rules
about how people will behave.
I think it's very
important to test
with everyone and their
partner and their parents.
Try to get really
outside the envelope.
JOEL PENNINGTON: And for many
of my clients and customers,
they're architects.
These are people who have
been architects or engineers
for decades.
So they are not gamers.
They take the Tango
tablet that we give them,
and the first challenge is
actually getting their design
onto the tablet.
So we had to build a pipeline
to go from our design software
to our game engine very
quickly and efficiently using
a whole bunch of cool
stuff on the cloud.
Once we get to their
design on the tablet,
the first thing they do
is, oh, this is neat.
You can move.
Oh, oh.
And then once they
start exploring,
they start to show their
coworkers how it functions.
And then you'll never
get the tablet back.
KYLE NEL: Yeah, I
think for us too
is we've done a lot
of this testing.
We're testing regular, normal
folks that had never even heard
of Tango or don't
follow any of this stuff
or even know what virtual
reality is really.
And giving it to somebody, there
is one woman in particular,
we explained what
virtual reality was
and what do you think?
She was like, virtual what?
And then at the end, we
didn't explain anything
else other than we
just gave it to her
and told her to explore with it.
And then she repeated
back everything
that we were trying to
convey had we just written
up a concept test and
explained all the key words.
And so that intuitive piece
is really, really important.
I think that's
what sets us apart.
And the other thing, too,
is the intuitive bit,
even though the form
factor is very intuitive,
there's still a
lot of challenges.
So for us, how do you
serve up 300 toilets
that look pretty much the
same in a virtual environment
without overwhelming people?
I mean, these are the
kind of challenges
that we hit all the time.
And to overcome some
of the learned behavior
and make it more intuitive.
KELLY SANTIAGO: Building
on that of bringing
in different
audiences and you guys
all come from
different backgrounds,
I'm wondering for this audience
of current and hopefully future
Tango developers, what are
some resources that you found
helpful to bring into your
work in augmented reality
and on Tango?
Either a specific tool or
philosophy or teaching?
ROBIN HUNICKE: I actually
spend a lot of time
looking at the works
of Disney and thinking
about the ways in which
park design and experience
design for physical
space really influences
the development of games and
playable spaces and activities.
Specifically attentional design.
So just really basic concepts
like having a weenie-- so
putting something
in the space that
will draw a person forward.
Like that the number one
challenge with Tango devices
is to get people to actually
move while holding it.
So you got to put something
in front of them that's
a little bit cute and a
little bit interesting
and a little bit sparkly
with a little glitter
and then they'll walk to it.
You need to bring them forward.
And if you make it sound
a little bit louder,
it feels nice.
And so if you want to
think about physical space
and physical design, you
need to really think about
what draws a person's attention
and how much motion should
things have?
And then, of
course, the opposite
of that, which is how do you
avoid cluttering the space?
How do you keep it simple?
These are things that you
can use whether you're
working on something like an
immersive 3D game like Journey
or Wattam or Luna
that we're building--
Luna is a VR title that
we're developing now.
Or something like
World, where it's
a very sparse set
of interactions
but they just immediately
spice up the space
because they bring that
magical feeling into it.
So that's something that I
think is really important.
JOEL PENNINGTON: On
the technical side
of things, the
developers and I, we're
very impressed
with how quickly we
were able to get ramped
up simply through access
to the API and the dogs.
So good job.
KYLE NEL: For us, we do
all of the things the same.
We don't do virtual
reality or augmented
reality for VR AR's sake.
We just think it's
the best way to solve
human problems and
human needs that people
have been asking for forever.
We call them common
cold problems.
It's like, you can
put a man on the moon,
but you can't-- so we think that
VR and AR solves that purpose,
and we use this thing where
we actually hire professional
science fiction writers
to envision the probable
convergence of tech and trends.
So we started doing this
about four years ago,
and if you look at
the original stories,
it looks a lot like Tango.
This is before the VR
emergence really showed up.
And so for us, it's
helping to focus
on what the solution is rather
than the technical capabilities
that we have right now.
And that changes-- I've
seen it-- the direction
in which the development takes.
Because you don't
take-- easiest is not
the best word-- but the one
with the least resistance path.
You take the solution
focused path.
And they sometimes
converge, but not always.
And that's really
been helpful for us.
JESSE SHELL: One thing
we've done a lot is not just
look-- it's so easy
when you're used
to developing apps and
software to just be thinking
about the digital
world, but when
you get into this realm
of spatial design,
you need to look at
real world things.
How is a model train
set designed and why?
How are LEGOs designed and why?
How big should things be?
How small should things be?
And you need to think about
things like am I designing
an experience that's about
interacting with things
on the floor, on a table,
while I'm standing, while I'm
moving around the house?
What exactly--
you're just having
to think about that
spatial context
and then taking
design inspiration,
we were taking a lot of design
inspiration from toys and play
sets and their
designs as opposed
to from video game space.
ROBIN HUNICKE:
Yeah, I was actually
going to say to follow up on
that that our office is filled
with clay, sculpting sand.
We have a lot of playmobil toys
and also a lot of plan toys.
Plan toys are really great
just in terms of form factor.
One of my favorite
ones, it's just
a simple base with
long planks coming out
of it that looks like a tree and
then it has a set of ladybugs.
And the tree has little spots
on it of different colors,
and you can put the ladybugs on
the colors using a colored dye.
So it's a way of teaching
kids how to match the colors,
but it's also a balancing game.
Because the more ladybugs you
place on the tree branches,
the more wobbly they get.
So we're really
interested specifically
in toys that are physical that
have some sort of a learning
component.
So early age
development toys are
really good for where
everyone's audience is going
to be in these technologies.
That's something
that Genova used
to say that when you put
someone into a new environment,
their response to
that environment
is going to be just like a baby.
They're going to poke
at stuff and they're
going to try to see
what it does and learn
what its physics and
its behaviors are.
So being in the mindset that
you're creating these learning
toys as opposed to
experiences, necessarily,
or applications
is really helpful,
and being able to engage the
playful qualities of people
of all ages is essential
for that design.
KELLY SANTIAGO: As far
as understanding space,
Joel, it seems like your
clients, architects, have
a really rich history in that.
How are they responding
to this new technology?
JOEL PENNINGTON: Well,
it's transformative.
If we go back a little bit,
blueprints were the best
that an architect
could do to visualize
what this new space,
this new city if you're
a civil engineer, would
look like and feel
like to the potential clients.
And that's a really terrible
way to communicate your design
intent-- full stop.
So then we moved to building
3D models of little cities
and buildings and
it looked cool.
It looked like LEGO.
But it didn't allow
the stakeholders--
the folks that are at
the town hall meetings--
to fully understand how is this
really going to impact my life?
It's not until
today where we have
access to immersive
technologies like game engines
and so forth that allow
you to really stick
your client into that
world and let them
understand what it's like
at a one-to-one scale.
Or should I want
to, let me fly over
to the other end of
the city and experience
what this construction project
will do to my daily commute?
We can simulate all of that and
we can visualize all of that
and give that person the
exact, true-to-life scenario
that they will see when
it's physically constructed.
And the architects
today are using
this not just for those really
important pitch projects where
they've really got
to win that new job,
they're actually using it
in daily design reviews
internally.
So they're not just showing
it to their clients,
they're using it for
their own design purposes.
Because design
software is amazing,
but it is required
to be so precise
and have so much
information in it,
that is like an anchor
pulling it down.
It doesn't allow it to be
live and rich in real time.
And we get that with
the Tango tablet.
KELLY SANTIAGO: That
is blowing my mind.
Sorry.
So whenever there is a
brand new space like this,
I think it's a
unique opportunity
to hit the reset button on how
we've been approaching media.
In television and film,
I feel like whether it's
for entertainment or for
education-- news programs,
you can see, take
a lot of their cues
from dramatic and
fictional programming.
And similarly, in
the digital space,
we still approach everything
with the divide of here
are apps and here are games.
And I'm wondering
if you see ways
in which we could be
developing or harvesting
this new developer ecosystem
of cross pollinating.
What are the
opportunities there?
JOEL PENNINGTON: If I may,
just very briefly, absolutely
the design requirements to
build a city, build a building,
make a thing that
you then want to get
funded by a Kickstarter require
expertise and design knowledge.
But if you want to
communicate your idea,
you have to do that
using new technology.
And game engines are
the way to do that.
And I will pass on.
I didn't want to take two
answers, but I had to.
ROBIN HUNICKE: I totally
agree that it's very important
to think about experience design
and applications and creativity
sharing-- the ways in which
we are all very social--
as well as the
designed experience.
And so I think for us, one
of the initial reactions
to the idea of using
a Tango device was,
well, it's going to be hard.
It won't look that good.
The world will be messy.
But when we started developing
with it, almost instantaneously
we were passing
the device around,
talking about the experience
that we were engaged in,
and then thinking
about I would totally
love to place this little
interactive snowman
on your head and
take a photo of it
and then share it with my mom.
That would be a funny photo.
And the idea of instantly
becoming aware of how social
the experience was.
And then also, because it's a
small form factor unlike a game
engine-- we normally
develop game engines
like Unity for PlayStation
3 and for high-end PCVRs,
so our experience has been
tethered by that technology.
With Tango, we were able to
experiment on a daily basis
and immediately
give the application
to other people in the office.
It was not uncommon
even during a meeting
for people to just get up and
start trying stuff and walking
around.
It was such a rapid
iteration cycle.
So for us, moving
toward applications
freed up our minds as developers
and really gave us permission
to try an experiment
in ways that we maybe
wouldn't have done if we were
working, like, in a big 3D
space in an engine with
a high-end visualization
technology.
So I think it goes both ways.
The lower resolution
allowed us to free ourselves
from expectations, which
limited our designs.
It's really honestly--
I said this before,
but I'll say it again-- it was
the most pleasant development
like pipeline experience
that I've had so far.
It was so fast and
so easy compared
to some of the clunkier stuff
that we've been working on.
KELLY SANTIAGO:
Jesse, I know you've
been thinking a lot as
we all have, but you
in particular have
been vocal as well
in sort of the future
of all this technology.
What are you excited to
see in the future of Tango
and augmented reality?
JESSE SHELL: So there's a lot
of talk about augmented reality
right now, and there's not
a lot of augmented reality
in the world.
It's mostly just
talk about something
that no one knows what it is.
And we could all hang out
and wait for a glasses size
perfect matrix augmented
reality to show up,
and maybe one day it will.
But in the meantime, what's
excited me is working
with Tango, we're already
learning the alphabet
of augmented reality.
We're learning
the best practices
because it's a system that's
here and it works today.
And this year,
you're going to be
able to make apps
for customers with.
And so that's one of
the things I love.
And back to your question
about this app-game divide,
the way I think
about that is apps
are generally about
creating something useful.
That's generally
what apps are for.
So here, go create
something useful.
And games are usually
about doing something fun.
And that middle space is about
creating something fun I think.
And that's why Minecraft
is so successful.
It's not a game,
it's an app that's
about creating something fun.
And Tango is one of
these things that
really allows you to
create a lot of things
in that middle place.
KELLY SANTIAGO: Cool.
Kyle, do you have any
thoughts about the future?
KYLE NEL: Yeah, I think that
there's a couple of pieces
there-- the business
side of things.
Obviously, there's a
tremendous opportunity
to be able to figure out how
you can take these gaming
learnings of what
works in games and then
be able apply it in this new
space that's not quite an app
but is something
wholly different.
And I like what you were
saying earlier about how
this is a platform change
much in the same way
that some of the other
platforms change in the past.
And coming at it
from that direction,
you start to think about
it differently hopefully.
But it's also beyond just
the development piece.
And thinking about it, there's
also an infrastructure thing
that has to change as well.
On our side, there's all
kinds of things we have to do.
Like the asset
creation process--
you have beautiful
3D assets that
work in different
environments and work
very well over different
kinds of networks.
And then how do you serve
that up in a meaningful way
without overwhelming people?
All these things we're beginning
to have to figure out now,
to your point, because it's
actually starting to arrive.
And from what I've seen
in the actual science
of the neuroscience
stuff, if you
don't think about it
intentionally and think about
it structurally in those
different ways beyond what
the person playing the
thing actually uses,
it will just be a mess.
And my worry is that
if we don't think
about those things
as a group and solve
some of those big challenges,
then the architecture
in which we continue
to develop will just
be messier and messier.
ROBIN HUNICKE: Yeah, there's
a real risk for lock-in right
now, and as developers,
it's all of our jobs
to think about what we
can do to really reverse
or un-learn, as
Jesse was saying,
bad lessons or just locked-in
assumptions about how people
operate and what they want.
People respond to
what you give them,
and you get what you give.
As a designer or
as a developer, you
have to be always giving more
and thinking about things
at a much broader
level than what's easy.
And I think one
of the best things
about being able to rapidly
iterate on technologies
like this is that you can
try a lot of things quickly,
you can put them
out there, you can
see how people respond
to them, and it's
a really rich environment for
questioning our own intuitions.
But it really is
our responsibility
to make sure that the next 100
years or 300 years of advances
in terms of us being able to
put ourselves into reality
in different ways
and to absorb reality
through different
lenses and filters
that we're really
thinking about this
from the perspective of
what is human in terms
of what doesn't stress the
body on a regular basis?
What doesn't stress the
cognitive on a regular basis?
How do we engage with
one another in safe ways?
And how do we allow
our imaginations
to be as broad and as open as
they can be and not just think
of everything as a tight little
package-- a single absorption?
Therefore, we want to streamline
it right into your brain.
But really give
people the opportunity
to be more expansive as humans.
This is something that we
will be designing right now,
and so stop thinking about
the mouse and the keyboard.
Stop thinking about
standard ways of input lists
and all this other stuff--
the clickable, scrollable UI.
There are so many other ways
to do things in these spaces,
and it's really in
all of your hands.
It's a very important
mission, I think.
JOEL PENNINGTON: When we look
at all of this cool new hardware
that's coming out that
enables augmented reality
and virtual reality
experiences, I firmly believe
that we'll all fall flat unless
there is content to support it.
And we're content creators.
But it is really tough to
make compelling content today.
At Autodesk, it is
no secret that we
have most of the software folks
used to make CG content today.
We also have our
game engine Stingray,
and right now, we've got
a very strong coupling
between that software
and the engine.
That lets us test and iterate
very quickly with architects
and game designers
and so forth that
want to be able to take their
assets that they've created
and their traditional
packages and get them
into that interactive
experience quickly
to elicit feedback
from charter users,
customers, gamers, and so forth.
KELLY SANTIAGO: Kyle, working
with a brand like Lowe's, I
would imagine it would have
additional complexities as far
as how much you're able to
iterate or rapidly iterate?
Is that true?
What's that process like
for you and your team?
KYLE NEL: Not many people
know that Lowe's started
as an augmented reality
company in the '40s.
We've just been
waiting a long time.
We decided selling home
improvement supplies was
a good way to build capital.
KELLY SANTIAGO: There's
a lot of responsibility
to physical spaces and
people of all kinds.
KYLE NEL: So without
waxing too philosophical,
Lowe's mission is to help
people love where they live,
and so the way that we
manifest that right now
is through building these
stores all over North America.
But clearly, that ambition
expands into the digital realm
as well.
And so when that's your goal,
the organization, hopefully,
will modify itself in order
to help achieve whatever
opportunities arise when you're
on this exponential path,
especially on AR and VR.
And so for us, when we started
down this a few years ago doing
different platforms
and we did that
with the intention of making
sure that the organization was
malleable-- we didn't know it
was going to be called Tango
or who was going to do it.
But when it arrived, we
would be ready-ish for it.
And ish is the key thing.
And if you talk to any large
organization on the planet,
not just a retailer, not just
a traditional business thing,
they're all trying to
understand how to engage people
in a more meaningful way.
And what more meaningful way
than the most intuitive way,
which right now I
think is clearly Tango?
So once again, for
us, it's about showing
what the promise could be
and the possibility could be
and then trying to-- I
don't know if beat up
is the right word,
but it's kind of what
I do is beat up the
organization so that they will
understand it and then jump on.
But I will say that Lowe's has
gotten behind this in a big way
because they see
the potential of it.
JESSE SHELL: Kyle, tell
them your job title.
KYLE NEL: I'm the executive
director of Lowe's Innovation
Labs and the vice president
of disruptive innovation.
So we were joking around
at breakfast this morning
that when people come
in and they're like,
Kyle is such a jerk, he made
me do this, I'm like, see,
I'm winning.
Success.
KELLY SANTIAGO: I
feel like that touches
on what Jesse was mentioning
as far as maybe having
this broad view that exists
outside of technology
so then you're ready
for the technology
as it manifests, which we
always know is not the utopia.
It's somewhere in the middle.
And then just be ready for
that and see what you can do.
It's cool.
What tips do you have for a
first time Tango developer?
JESSE SHELL: Oh, I've got a lot.
The big thing is
to keep it simple.
You're going to have to
find your way in terms
of what works.
You're going to have a lot
of big dreamy ideas about all
the wonderful things
that are going to work.
And not everything
is going to work yet.
It's a platform that
has its strengths
and has its weaknesses.
If you go in-- and I think
we did this initially.
We started playing
around with it 18 months
or two years ago--
something like that.
And we had this big
dream of exactly how
it was going to work.
And when it didn't
work exactly that way,
we we're like we hate this.
And then a little later,
we were like, well,
maybe we should just
do what it's good at.
And then we started
focusing on that,
and then we started making
all of this path forward.
So I think going in
with an open mind
and looking for what it's good
at, and you'll find things.
Like we ended up
finding oh my god,
it's really good
at playing Jenga.
And this just hadn't
occurred to anybody,
but it was because we started
thinking where is this strong
and what can it do?
ROBIN HUNICKE: I
would say also just
really being open to trying
the weirdest and most bizarre
idea that you have.
Keita is incredibly irreverent
when it comes to reality.
He just doesn't like the
fact that there's gravity
and that we have limitations
of physical bodies
and that we can't just
appear to each other
as giant Teddy Bears or
animating carrots or whatever.
He wants the world to be a
really magical place in ways
that are sometimes very
frustrating to him.
So his first
experience with Tango
was to immediately ask can we
hang things on the ceiling?
Can I make a cloud
that will rain
and then little
flowers will sprout?
How can I engage in this reality
in a way that totally questions
what we expect?
And so to give
yourself permission
to just have the strange idea
and put it in, because it
is so easy, it is so fast.
It was so possible for us
to add features and get them
into the pipeline and testable
within the same day of having
a meeting.
It would be in the device.
And so don't lock
yourself into this pattern
of thinking you have
to flow everything out.
Really go with what the
device is good with,
but specifically, ask
yourself, why not as opposed
to sort of always trying
to detail exactly why.
JOEL PENNINGTON: And
then give it to people
and watch them play with it.
That's the most amazing reaction
because they start small,
and then once they
realize what they can do,
you'll never get
the tablet back.
You're just going to have
to go buy another one.
ROBIN HUNICKE: It's true.
It's true.
We're always having people
jealous of people interacting
with the Tango device at work.
People cluster around
and try to touch it.
KYLE NEL: And to add onto that,
it's been really helpful for us
after you hand somebody--
a normal person who
doesn't do this all the time
and have them experience it,
have them explain it to somebody
else sitting right next to them
about how they
would talk about it.
There's so many different
things that came out of it.
Like, oh my gosh, I never
even-- that's really
what you got out of that?
And that's really
what you wanted?
And it just takes you
in different directions.
KELLY SANTIAGO: Yeah,
you were talking
earlier, Robin, before
the panel about designing
around the constraints.
And Jesse was kind of touching
on this too-- there are
strengths and there
are weaknesses.
And so when you find out maybe
that original idea doesn't
quite work, OK,
well, how can I lean
into what the strengths
of the platform are?
ROBIN HUNICKE: Yeah, I
think that we actually
felt comfortable
rolling our own when
it came to certain
aspects of the system.
We especially wanted people to
be able to set up a little play
area and then walk away from
it and come back and have
it persist.
So we were able to use
features of the device
to make that happen.
And then in places where we
were struggling a little bit,
we just wrote software that
took care of that problem
from a different perspective.
So we would ask ourselves
what is this really about?
So for example, being
able to leave a place
and then come back
to it is really
about matching the picture in
your mind to what you built.
So we built something where
you take a picture with it,
and then later, you just
line up the picture,
and it's there again.
And people will do a lot.
They will give
you a lot in order
to have that fun experience.
They haven't learned that
the technology is supposed
to solve all of our problems.
When we first started working
with Tango developers,
Nick [INAUDIBLE] and
some of the other people
that we were working
with in the organization
gave us this big, long
list of all these things
that we would have to
educate users to do.
And I said, do you want me to
write you a use case tutorial
or do you want to game design?
Because I can design around
like 30% to 70% of these things
depending on how creative the
people are on the project.
Let's not think about all the
limitations of the technology,
let's think about the couple
of things it does well
and what we can get people
to give us for free.
And so that's the other
thing that you can really
do with something this simple
is you can get a lot for free.
People are not
expecting the world
to be given to
them on a platter,
and honestly, our user
testing on Google Campus,
when people experience
it, they're blown away.
They're literally
like, this is so cool.
It does so much cool stuff.
I had no idea.
And in your mind as a developer,
you're imagining the holodeck.
So you're like, it's
not the holodeck.
This is not Data doing
a Sherlock Holmes
thing in real time.
Your limitations are so
much greater than the user.
The everyday person
who picks up a Tango
will literally be blown
away, so don't limit yourself
in that way.
KELLY SANTIAGO: So we just
have a few minutes left.
I'm wondering if real
quickly we can put back
the slide with the
speaker's information on it
and you can see their
Twitter accounts.
Let's give a hand for
all our awesome panelists
and developers.
Thank you for sharing
your lessons learned
and for coming out here.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]